do something you're very passionate
about and don't try to chase what is
kind of the hot Passion of the day I
think we saw it in the internet World
quite a bit where you know at the sort
of peak of the internet in say 1999
found people who were very passionate
something they kind of left that job and
decided I'm gonna you know do something
in the internet because it's you know it
was almost like the 1849 gold rush in a
way at that time everybody who was in
was within the shouting distance of
California was you know they might have
been a doctor but they quit being a
doctor and they started panning for gold
and that almost never works and even if
it does work you know According to some
Metric financial success or whatever it
might be I suspect it leaves you
ultimately unsatisfied so you really
need to be very clear with yourself and
I think one of the best ways to do that
is this notion of projecting yourself
forward to age 80 looking back on your
life and trying to make sure you've
minimized the number of rats you have
that works for career decisions it works
for family decisions need motivation
watch the top 10 with hashtag believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because of my first
business I quit on my business partner I
struggled to keep going I was making 300
bucks a month and felt like a complete
failure and the thing that saved me that
pulled me up was studying the stories of
famous entrepreneurs I got the
motivation from them I also got the
strategies of what to do next so that I
can go off and achieve my dreams and
quite honestly I still need the stories
today myself to continue my motivation
to take it to the next level so today
that's on from one of the best Jeff
Bezos and my take on his top 10 rules of
success enjoy thank you
rule number two be Innovative you've
built one of the greatest technology
companies in the world in just 20 some
years you've taken a company from
nothing to Amazon which everybody in the
world now knows and and most people in
the world seem to use was that harder to
do than trying to get a space company
off the ground which is more of a
challenge to you
totally different challenges so one of
the things that I find if I think back
on the last 20 years you have to
remember 20 years ago I was driving the
packages to the post office myself in my
1987 Chevy Blazer dreaming that one day
I might be able to afford a forklift and
the internet that's 1995 and you know 21
years later the internet is this
gigantic thing and there are many many
successful companies and the
entrepreneurial dynamism
that you see on the internet is
incredible and really with blue origin
you know that this new challenge I'm
taking on with the origin what I want to
do is put the heavy lifting
infrastructure in place so that the Next
Generation can have a dynamic
entrepreneurial explosion of ideas and
inventions in space just like we've had
with the internet and the reason you
can't do that today is because there's
just too much heavy lifting involved
literally you know getting to space is
so expensive and so hard when we started
Amazon I didn't have to build a
logistics infrastructure system to
deliver Parcels there was something
already UPS already existed in the U.S
Postal Service already existed I didn't
need to build a remote payment system
there are already credit cards and
similarly you know there were computers
around and you know that didn't have to
get all those things would have been
tens of billions or hundreds of billions
of dollars of infrastructure the long
distance phone network became the
backbone of the internet but it already
existed and so you could have this
Dynamic entrepreneurial explosion
because all the heavy capex
infrastructure was in place for space
it's not like that the price of
admission is so high so that's the big
difference and what I'm super excited
about is lowering that cost I want to
dramatically lower that cost so that 20
years from now a new generation of
people with startup money real real
entrepreneurs small entrepreneurs can do
amazing things in space think how cool
that would be rule number three find
your faith if we look back on our past
with a watchful eye
what we see is a message of Hope
we have been confronting challenges
since we have been writing history
and we have always found the faith to
rise above them
nevertheless once again
it is time to sit down
find our faith and get to work
because despite everything that those
who came before us have already done
we still find ourselves in a world with
astronomical need
our past achievements must be used to
inform today's problems but not mask
their reality
it is time once again to do what many
will say is impossible rule number four
prioritize your sleep I get eight hours
of sleep I prioritize it unless I'm
traveling in different time zones
sometimes it's impossible but I am very
um focused on it and and for me I need
eight hours of sleep I think better I
have more energy my mood is better all
these things and think about it as a
senior executive
what do you really get
um paid to do as a senior executive you
get paid to make a small number of high
quality decisions
your your job is not to make thousands
of decisions every day so let's say that
I
slept six hours a day or let's go really
crazy and say I slept four hours a day
so now I just got four so-called
productive hours back
so if I was going to you know have say
12 hours of productive time during any
waking day now all of a sudden I have 12
plus four I have 16 productive hours so
I have 33
more
time to make decisions so if I was going
to make you know 100 decisions now I can
make 133 Decisions by the if I did that
arithmetic wrong
I'm sorry and
um and so you make 133 decisions is that
really worth it if the quality of those
decisions might be lower because you're
tired or grouchy or any number of things
now it's different if it's a startup
company I mean you know you're really
you know when Amazon was 100 people it's
a different story but but Amazon's not a
startup company and all of our senior
Executives operate the same way I do
they work in the future they live in the
future none of the people who report to
me should really be focused on the
current quarter I always tell people
sometimes I get you know we'll have a
good
um quarterly conference call or
something and and Wall Street will like
our quarterly results and I'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and I
say thank you but what I'm really
thinking is
a quarter was baked three years ago I
right now I'm working on a quarter
that's going to reveal itself in 2021
sometime and that's what you need to be
doing you need to be out sort of you
know two or three years in advance and
if you are and then why do I need to
make a hundred decisions today if I make
like three good decisions a day that's
enough and they should just be as high
quality as I can make them Warren
Buffett says he's good if he makes three
good decisions a year also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video app absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five
experiment how do you encourage your
employees to be innovative
well this is a fantastic and important
question
um to be Innovative you have to
experiment if you want
to have more invention you need to do
more experiments per week per month per
year per decade it's that simple you
cannot invent without experimenting
and here's the other thing about
experiments
lots of them fail
if you know it's going to work in
advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that Amazon's a big organization now too
the Air Force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation with operational
excellence
so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles that
Amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now we know how
to do that
that is not an experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up
that's just a failure
that's not the kind of failure we're
seeking we want failures where we're
trying to do something new untested
never proven that's a real experiment
and they come in all scale sizes so you
need to teach people that those two
kinds of failure are different
um and you need to have you said
something about that hard Middle where
ideas don't sure go up I think this is
such an important uh thing at Amazon one
of the things we try to do is have
multiple paths to yes rule number six
fulfill your dreams what prompted you
after you've started Amazon to start a
whole separate company and how much of
your time do you devote to it
well I had I had been hoping to build a
space company since I was a little kid
and um and then you know kind of reality
came into play and I realized it was
going to be really expensive to start a
space company and then I kind of
moved on I fell in love with computers
and um and then I won this kind of
Lottery called amazon.com and then I
realized hey wait I can do that original
childhood dream now and so I started
this company and it employs now we're up
to about 700 people and we're building a
suborbital tourism vehicle which
competes with Virgin Galactic and we're
gonna our goal there is to make it
possible ultimately for anybody who
wants to go to space to be able to
afford it we're just going to keep
working at that goal patiently until we
achieve it and and then we're also
building an orbital vehicle and we'll
we'll fly that at the end of this decade
for the first time and so it is you know
and and my my belief is that to
dramatically lower the cost of space
it's all about reusability you just have
to make your vehicles reusable you can't
throw them in the bottom of the ocean
every time after you use them if you
ever want to dramatically reduce the
cost so would you go on one of these
space trips yourself yeah absolutely I
fully expect to go into space myself
someday and um
they're sitting here in the front row so
I'm telling them right now no they know
the Amazon share they know I can't be
kept away rule number seven do good
deeds talk to me about choosing Dolly
Parton well uh look at what she's done
and and how she's led her life and the
way she's done it these bold things
always with Civility and kindness she's
a unifier you know we have big problems
in the world and the way to get big
problems done is you have to work
together we have too many examples in
the world of conflict and people using
ad hominem attacks on social media and
so on and so on you won't find Dolly
Parton doing that do you plan to give
away the majority of your wealth in your
lifetime yeah I do and and the hard part
is figuring out how to do it in a
levered way it's not easy
um you know building Amazon was not easy
it took a lot of hard work a bunch of
very smart teammates and I'm finding and
I think Lauren's finding the same thing
that philanthropy is very similar it's
not easy it's really hard and there are
a bunch of ways that you I think that
you could do ineffective things too so
we're building the capacity to be able
to give away this money rule number
eight think long term talk to me about
long-term thinking and your point of
view on well long-term thinking is a
lever it lets you do things that you
could not do or couldn't even conceive
of doing if you were thinking short term
so if I you know that's why you know I
have a project where I'm helping a group
of people build the a ten thousand year
clock it kind of ticks once a year and
dongs once a century and the cuckoo
comes out once a millennium it's a it's
a big 500 foot tall thing inside a
mountain right here inside one of those
mountain range
and the ten thousand year clock is a
symbol I don't think it'll do anything
for the first few hundred years but
after a few hundred years once it's old
people start to pay attention to older
symbols and so a few hundred years from
now I hope that people will think about
that as a symbol for long-term thinking
if I you know if if I collaborated with
somebody here in this audience and I
said look I want you to solve world
hunger and I want you to do it in five
years you would
properly reject the opportunity you
would say look it's not possible it's
not practical but if I said look I want
you to solve world hunger in a hundred
years that's a job you'd take because
it's a much more addressable problem you
can first create the conditions you have
time to create the conditions where then
you can solve the problem and so that's
that's a very important way of thinking
and um and I find it's and it works with
everything I mean you have to back up
and find the right time Horizon for what
you're trying to do but you know at
Amazon we probably do most of our things
we expect to get some results in sort of
five six seven eight years but we find a
lot of our
uh you know other companies that compete
against us in various ways they're often
trying to get things done in you know
two or three years and so we can do
things that you know if you if
everything has to work in two to three
years
then that limits what you can do if you
give yourself the the breathing room to
say okay I'll I'm okay if it takes seven
years all of a sudden you have way more
opportunities rule number nine learn to
balance I get asked by people at all age
ranges all levels of seniority what do I
think about work-life balance and my
view on work like work life balance is
that I prefer the phrase work life
Harmony
um to me balance implies a strict
trade-off and I have seen situations
where people
are they have all the time in the world
maybe they're out of work they have lots
of time that you know it's they don't
have they have all all the time and
they're so stressed
that they're actually terrible at home
everybody at home is like boy I sure
wish you get a job
um
and uh my sister-in-law says for better
for worse but not for lunch
um
and so it's you you've you you you you
you really want Harmony you want a um if
you're happy at work
if you're finding meaning in your work
if you are
um it can be hard they call it work for
a reason it's not going to be fun all
the time that's a pipe dream none of us
enjoys every minute of every day and to
have that kind of idea would just be
naive but there should be fun at work
you should be laughing there should be
moments of joy
and if you're getting energy from work
instead of your work draining your
energy then you're going to come home
and you're going to be a better mother a
better father a better wife a better
husband all of those things you're going
to want to take out the trash
and so even before being asked that's
what's going to happen Larry she's going
to say
who is this guy
and so you really need to I think if
you're starting to get to the point
where you are worried about work-life
balance I would challenge you to think
is just something out of whack it's
probably not the hours look you can if
you're working 120 hours a week you're
also doing something wrong that's too
much you it's not sustainable maybe you
can do that for a week or two but that's
it but if you're working you know 60
hours a week that's completely
sustainable for most people and the
question if you're burned out by it it's
not the number of hours
it's this it's you're doing something
wrong you need to figure out what it is
because you're going to take that home
and then your home life is going to be
stressful and you're going to bring that
back into the office so it's going to be
a negative spiral and that spiral will
also be a positive one as soon as you
turn it around and Rule Number 10 the
last home before some very special bonus
Clips is protect the environment major
corporations all of us committed to
reaching the Paris Accord goals 10 years
early by 2040.
why are all these companies doing this
well like all of us they care about the
planet
we all live on it
but it's also because they see that
there is a new economic World emerging
and they want to be part of it
uh you want to drive this new economy
and not let it drive you so so thank you
all of you for your bold leadership in
helping to fight climate change
tonight I'd like to speak about nature
the loss of Nature and the changing
climate aren't really two separate
problems
they are two sides of the same coin
we simply cannot address climate change
without reversing the loss of Nature and
vice versa
first of all
I love space I have been a space lover
since I was a five-year-old boy
and I feel like I won the lottery with
Amazon I know I won the lottery and uh
and now I'm investing those lottery
winnings in blue origin which is the
space company
we built we're built we are flying a sub
orbital tourism vehicle and we'll start
taking people up hopefully in 2018
that's coming right up working on it for
more than 10 years
hopefully this one this is this
overnight success is taking longer than
10 years I don't know we'll see you know
uh and we're also building an orbital
vehicle called New Glen new Shepherd is
named it for Alan Shepard the first
American in space he went on a
suborbital journey new Glen is named
after the American hero John Glenn who
was the first American to orbit the
earth uh and
so these are both these are reusable
boosters fully reusable that's the key
to lowering the cost our vision of blue
origin is that we want millions of
people living and working in space and
my personal hope is that I live long
enough to see
um the kind of dynamism in space I want
to see a whole economy entrepreneurs in
space that I got to witness over the
last 20 years on the internet you know
um the the problem with being an
entrepreneur in the space arena is that
the price of admission is so darn High
so it you know to do interesting things
in Space the beginning you know kind of
the beginning entry level is a few
hundred million dollars so you're not
going to get you know two kids in their
dorm room doing something amazing in
space whereas that's literally what
happened to Facebook right so on the
internet because the price of admission
is so low
you can get these amazing experiments
where like one kid in the dorm room does
something and it turns into Facebook and
or you know Amazon's case you know I
started this thing with an incredibly
small amount of capital
and the you know it was able to grow
because we didn't need a lot to get to
begin with the heavy lifting was in
place for Amazon right so I didn't need
to build a transportation Network it
existed already it was ups and the Royal
Mail and the U.S Postal Service and
Deutsche Post and so on and so on I
didn't have to build a
telecommunications backbone to connect
with my customers it was there it was
called the internet and in fact the
internet was resting on top of the long
distance phone network at that time you
guys remember the dial-up motive some of
you do some of you are too young to some
of you should go to a museum and see a
dial-up modem what was that sound yeah
and so
my one I I recently showed a group of
youngsters a pay phone I came across one
and I was like my God guys come over
here this may be the last one you have
to see it
um and uh so you know the point is that
Amazon was got to rest on top of we
didn't have to build a payment system it
already existed it was called the credit
card
um computers were already on every desk
thanks to you know Microsoft IBM and
apple and but what were they being used
for to play games not to buy things on
Amazon and so all that heavy lifting was
in place and I want to you know my
greatest uh uh I would have such a good
feeling if I could be an 80 year old guy
and laying there thinking about my life
if I could say look there is
um now a bunch of entrepreneurs in space
because I took my Amazon lottery
winnings and built the heavy lifting
infrastructure that does take billions
of dollars in capex to lower the cost of
access to space that's how you get
millions of people living at work and by
the way we need that for those of you
who like to think about the future
at all you can do a simple calculation
you know you we can argue about
um you know what limited resources on
Earth and so on and so on but here's the
calculation that you cannot argue with
which is you take current Baseline
energy usage on Earth compound it at
just a few percent a year for just a few
hundred years and you have to cover the
entire surface of the Earth and solar
cells
so
you have to we're going to have to
decide do we want a society of
pioneering invention expansion growth or
do we want a society of stasis
and personally I believe because the
Earth is finite and if you want a
society of stasis I think it's good
first of all I don't personally believe
the stasis is even compatible with
freedom so I think for me that's a big
problem second of all
it's going to be dull
stasis is going to be very dull you
don't want to live in the stasis world
and so of course we're going to continue
to get more efficient too we have been
for hundreds of years we've been getting
more productive more efficient that's
that trend is going to continue but even
so we're going to want to use more
energy more energy per capita and also I
don't want to stabilize population I
would love for there to be a trillion
humans in the solar system with a
trillion humans we would have a thousand
Einsteins and a thousand mozarts it'd be
an incredible symbol don't you want that
dynamism it'd be so much interesting my
this is for your great great
grandchildren but what kind of world do
you want them to live in I want them to
live in that expansive world that is you
know uh learning more about the universe
and moving out throughout the solar
system so that we have to do it and um
anyway so it's fun to work on that and
uh uh uh you know I get I have a I won
so many lotteries in my life
um I have the best parents in the world
my mom Jackie and my dad Mike my mom had
me when she was 17 in Albuquerque New
Mexico she was still in high school it
was not cool
and she did an amazing job my dad Mike
is a Cuban immigrant who came here when
he was 16 without his parents did an
amazing job so those are the things that
are your little gifts in life you get
sometimes you get my greatest admiration
by the way is withheld for those people
and I know several of them who had
terrible parents
and still somehow made it through that's
hard
that I had the opposite so I got elected
is there a particular recipe that you
have in terms of how you actually
innovate in that collaborative culture
I think um and I don't I don't think
there's a particular recipe but there
are elements of what we do that I think
help so one of them is that inside our
culture we understand that even though
we have some big businesses new
businesses start out small and so you
know it would be very easy for say the
person who runs our U.S books
category to say why are we doing these
experiments with things I mean you know
that generated you know a tiny bit of
Revenue last year
um uh why don't we instead Focus those
resources and that uh you know that all
that brain power on this on the books
category where we which is a big
business for us and uh instead that
would be a natural thing to have happen
but instead inside Amazon you know when
a new business you know reaches some
small Milestone of sales email messages
go around and everybody's you know
giving virtual high fives for reaching
that Milestone and I think it's because
we know from our past experiences that
big things start small uh you know the
biggest Oak starts from an acorn and
you've got to recognize if you want to
do anything new
you've got to be willing to let that
Acorn grow into a little sapling and
then finally into a small tree and maybe
one day it'll be
a big business on its own and in fact
that's one of the mottos for one of your
initiatives and forgive my my
pronunciation of the Latin but Greta
team for Oct what does that mean to you
well it means uh step-by-step
ferociously and it's the motto for blue
origin
um and uh basically you can't skip steps
you have to put one foot in front of the
other things take time uh you there are
no shortcuts and uh but but you want to
do those steps with you know passion and
ferocity blue origin is a um
a space a company that's developing a
vertical takeoff vertical Landing space
vehicle
and so it takes off on its tail like a
normal rocket and then comes back and
lands on its tail like a Buck Rogers
rocket it's designed to be reusable
we've built our first development
vehicle we built our second development
vehicle right now working on our third
development vehicle great team of
Engineers located in Seattle another
team of people test and operations in
West Texas where we do our flights and
it's it's proceeding along very nicely
I'm hopeful that this third development
vehicle will be our last but we can't
know for sure and then we will build our
operational vehicle and start taking
people to suborbital Mission we'll sell
tickets the long-term goal of blue
origin is to not only do suborbital but
also orbital and to democratize
space travel so that anybody who wants
to go into space can afford to do so you
need reusability
so when you go look at any approach that
doesn't have reusability is never going
to be low cost there are only two
problems with space travel today it's
too expensive and it's too dangerous
other than that it's fine so we hope to
solve
those two problems and if you want to
solve those problems and have a
space-faring species you need to you
need to practice
and you can't practice with Expendable
Vehicles it's like you know it's flying
your you know you get onto 747 with a
bunch of other passengers fly to Hawaii
and then throw the whole plane away it's
just a bad it's a bad cost structure and
so we need reusability so you have to
get the vehicle back
and one of the ways to get it back is to
put Wings on it and then you can land it
on a Runway another way to get the
vehicle back is to
land it vertically under under rocket
power and both techniques have
advantages and disadvantages one of the
things I like about vertical Landing is
if you get it to work it's very scalable
it's skills to very very large size
whereas Wings sort of you know they top
out a bit one of the things that we know
about
uh Amazon as a role model for this is
that our business is it's a difficult
challenge for us because we have deep
large physical infrastructure we're not
only moving information around we're
moving packages around we deliver 10
billion items more than 10 billion items
a year this is real physical
infrastructure at real scale and so we
can make the argument and we plan to do
so passionately that if we can do this
anyone can do this it's going to be
challenging but we know we can do it and
we know we have to do it where are we
today
today we're at 40 percent renewable
energy we've done that by building 15
utility scale solar and wind farms we've
put rooftop installations on fulfillment
centers and sortation centers around the
world
where are we going well on renewable
energy by 2024 we're committing to be at
80 renewable energy and by 2030 we're
committing to be at a hundred percent
renewable energy
we're also we have a lot of delivery
events and they all burn fossil fuels
today I'm incredibly excited to announce
that we have just placed an order for
000 electric delivery events they'll be
built by a company called rivien this is
another example of uh something very
important I want to talk about which is
that when you make a pledge like the
climate pledge it will drive the economy
to start to build products and services
that these large companies need to meet
those commitments this is why we
invested in rivian we invested 440
million dollars in rivian that's part of
what I'm so excited about as this
economy develops and people get serious
about being carbon zero through real
changes to their real business
activities that is going to be a
gigantic signal to the marketplace to
start inventing develop helping these
new technologies that these global
companies will need to be able to meet
this commitment and so that's another
reason we have to work together we have
to get a number of companies to sign up
for this to really drive that market
signal in a strong way Amazon is large
but if we get lots of large companies to
agree to the same thing that would be an
even stronger signal to the market that
together with the fact that the supply
chains are so interconnected it becomes
the only way to do it and that's with
collaboration I did do a lot of soul
searching I I went to my boss at the
time and I really liked my job and I
told my boss I was going to go do this
thing started an internet bookstore and
my wife had already told my wife and
she's like great let's go and I I said
to my boss I'm going to this he's like
this is a good idea so I think this is a
good idea but it would be an even better
idea for somebody who didn't already
have a good job and that sort of made
some logical sense to me and he can just
be to think about it for a couple of
days so I went away I was really trying
to get my head around how to think about
this and I think
for me the right way to make that kind
of very personal decision because those
decisions are personal they're not like
data-driven business decisions they're
they are you know what does your heart
say and for me it was I could the best
way to think about it was to project
myself forward to age 80 and say look
when I'm 80 years old I want to have
minimized the number of regrets that I
have I don't want to be 80 years old in
a quiet moment of reflection thinking
back over my life and and cataloging a
bunch of major regrets and I think that
regrets our biggest regrets in most
cases you can murder somebody okay you'd
regret that but in most cases
our biggest regrets turn out to be acts
of O Mission it's paths not taken and
they haunt us we wonder what would have
happened I loved that person and I never
told them and then they married somebody
else I did you know I didn't do this and
so that's the frame of mind that I put
myself in and I and once I did that once
I thought about it that way it was
immediately obvious to me I knew that
when I'm 80 I would never regret trying
this thing that I was super excited
about
and failing if it failed fine I would be
very proud of the fact when I'm 80 that
I tried and I also
um knew that I it would always haunt me
if I didn't try and so that would be a
regret it would be a 100 chance of a
regret if I didn't try and basically a
zero percent chance of regret if I tried
and failed so well I think that's a
useful metric for any important life
decision I laugh a lot
um
so it is a
you know there are I I think stress you
can be uh like one of the things that's
very important to note about stress is
the stress primarily comes from not
taking action over something that you
can have some control over so if I find
that some particular thing is causing me
to have stress that's a a a a warning
flag for me what it means is there's
something that I haven't completely
identified perhaps in my conscious mind
that is bothering me and I haven't yet
taken any action on it I find as soon as
I identify it and make the first phone
call or send off the first email message
or whatever it is that we're going to do
to start to address that situation even
if it's not solved the mere fact that
we're addressing it dramatically reduces
any stress that might come from it so
stress comes from ignoring things that
you shouldn't be ignoring I think in
large part so stress does doesn't come
people get stress wrong all the time in
my opinion stress doesn't come from hard
work for example you know you can be
working incredibly hard and loving it
and likewise you can be out of work and
Incredibly stressed over that
so and likewise if you kind of use the
you know use that as an analogy for what
I was just talking about if you're out
of work but you're going through you
know a disciplined approach of you know
a series of job interviews and so on and
working to remedy that situation you're
going to be a lot less stressed than if
you're just worrying about it and doing
nothing let's talk about failures I know
Amazon has had its share of feelings in
fact I remember having been part of some
of them at Amazon
I'm curious to know how do you think
about failure and how should we we deal
with failure when we see it
sun is the best place in the world to
fail
and the reason for that is we have a lot
of practice
nobody likes to fail by the way failure
even when you know it's important and
good it's embarrassing
um
it doesn't feel good we're all human we
had a good idea we thought it was a good
idea and nobody came to the party
that happens and here's the great thing
though
one success One winner can pay for
dozens and dozens of failures
and that is why it should fail we got
this company just about ready to launch
and uh we're looking at it and looking
at this little tiny fulfillment center
we were here by then in this building we
had a basement fulfillment center to
call the Fulfillment center was very
Grand there's a lot of puffery it was
400 square feet which is about the size
of a one-car garage and we launched this
uh business and we're looking at it and
we didn't know if anybody would order
from us we really didn't and in fact one
of the software Engineers looked at this
little space and he said I can't figure
out whether this is incredibly
optimistic or hopelessly pathetic
um and indeed we didn't know we had no
idea whether anybody would want to buy
things in this way the Business Plan
called for uh generating sales very
slowly as customers changed their
attitudes the original business plan
which I thought was very optimistic at
the time called for amazon.com to
generate 70 million dollars in sales in
the year 2001. we actually generated in
excess of three billion dollars in sales
in the year 2001 and we knew by the way
that we're really on to something in
those first 30 days in the first 30 days
we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries with not a dollar of
advertising just all word of mouth in
the first year we didn't spend anything
on Advertising all of it was word of
mouth and that really forged the company
as a that we were going to focus on
customer experience because we saw the
power of word of mouth so so very very
clearly in those early days there's
something great about Word of Mouth
online by the way and feedback from
customers which is that email turns off
the politeness Gene in the human being
it's wonderful so people actually tell
you what they really think usually in
all caps
um
and uh
so we get lots of info and feedback from
our customers and we try to try to use
it well a Professional Pride part is so
important because ninety percent of what
all of you do nobody ever sees
it's something it's inside the work
people see something finished but they
don't see what's inside it only you see
that while you're doing the work
and that so you have those and those
things can't be great since nobody's
seen them nobody's inspecting it you're
not going to get any credit for it the
only thing that's going to make you have
high standards on that piece of the work
that nobody's ever going to see is your
own Professional Pride in operational
excellence those are the four cultural
attributes
that are at Amazon we use the same ones
of blue origin we use the same ones the
W AWS
those things
I would if they start to erode at the
edges that would make me very nervous so
I spent a lot of time
trying to inspect that audit that teach
that teaching things like that is about
repetition senior leaders need to be
broken records on the things that are
important to the organization and if
everybody in the organization like you
you have succeeded when you start to see
people roll their eyes because of your
repetition on certain important things
because senior leaders don't have to do
a lot of things they have to pick a few
Big Ideas and enforce tough execution
against those big ideas and that
requires a lot of repetition
directionally our goal and this has been
true for it's kind of a cultural trait
at Amazon our focus is going to be to be
the low-cost provider of these kinds of
high quality services
so as we are able to get smarter as
we're able to you know figure out how to
do things more efficiently we are going
to be returning those cost efficiencies
to customers in the form of lower prices
on things like ec2 there are other
things that you know that it may be that
we need some instance sizes is instance
sizes sizes that are smaller than what
we have today
so the smallest instance we have today
is 10 cents per compute hour and we're
also looking you know always at you know
returning some of the cost savings we
get on things like bandwidth charges
disk space charges and so on and so on
the good news is that those things do
get cheaper over time and as we get more
efficient and organized we'll be able to
return I think quite a bit of savings to
customers one of the great paradoxes of
inventing at a high level
is that you need to be an expert in your
domain area
and you need to have a beginner's mind
you absolutely need both of those things
the world is too complex to actually
just be a beginner so you know I can't
no matter how inventive I am I can't go
invent a new kind of brain surgery
you have to be a neurosurgeon you have
to already know all there is to know
about brain surgery and then take it to
the next level the problem is for many
people by the time they become true
experts they've lost that ability to see
things in a fresh way they've lost The
Beginner's mind
and so that's another thing you always
need to be stepping back and saying if I
I'm an expert I'm an expert in launch
vehicles or whatever it is
I I need to step back and say okay
if I were looking at this for the first
time what would I be seeing and noticing
these are just some of the things you
need to do to be Innovative day two
is stasis
followed
by irrelevance
by excruciating
painful decline
followed by Death
[Music]
and that
is why
it is always
day one I um went to my boss and said to
him you know I'm gonna go do this crazy
thing and I'm gonna start this uh this
company selling books online and this is
something that I already been talking to
him about in a sort of more General
context but then he said let's go on a
walk and we went on a two-hour walk in
Central Park in New York City
and the conclusion of that was this he
said you know this actually sounds like
a really good idea to me but it sounds
like it would be a better idea for
somebody who didn't already have a good
job
and he convinced me to think about it
for 48 hours before making a final
decision and so I went away and and and
was trying to find the right framework
in which to make that kind of big
decision and you know I'd already talked
to my wife about this and she was very
supportive and said look you know you
can count me in 100
whatever you want to do you know it's
true she had married this kind of you
know fairly stable guy in a stable
career path and now he wanted to go do
this crazy thing but she was 100
supportive so it really was a decision
that I had to make for myself
and the and the framework I found which
made the decision incredibly easy was
what what I called which only a nerd
would call a regret minimization
framework so I wanted to project myself
forward to age 80. and so okay now I'm
looking back on my life I want to have
minimize the number of regrets I have
and you know I knew that when I was 80 I
was not going to regret having tried
this I was not going to regret having
wanted you know trying to participate in
this thing called the internet that I
thought was going to be a really big
deal I knew that if I failed I wouldn't
regret that but I knew the one thing I
might regret is not ever having tried
and I knew that that would haunt me
every day and so when I thought about it
that way it was an incredibly easy
decision
and I think that's a very good it's it's
if you can project yourself out to age
80 and sort of think what will I think
at that time it gets you away from some
of the daily pieces of confusion you
know I left this Wall Street firm in the
middle of the year when you do that you
walk away from your annual bonus and
that's the kind of thing then the short
term can confuse you but if you think
about the long term then you can really
make good life decisions that you won't
regret later
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Elon Musk check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there everything is
available basically for free you can
learn anything you want for free it is
not a question of learning
um there there is a value that colleges
have which is like